[Music]
hello and welcome to crosstalk where all
things are considered i'm peter level
u.s secretary of state mike pompeo is on
a mission
he claims the world must change china or
china will change us
how should we interpret this a cold war
to be waged against beijing
does this also imply forced regime
change
china is certainly a major global
competitor but is it now
our enemy
[Music]
to discuss this and more i'm joined by
my guest victor gao in
beijing he is chair professor at sochao
university and
in stanford we cross to daniel wagner he
is ceo of country risk solutions as well
as
author of chinavision the america china
divine and his new book on
the belt and road initiative the chinese
vortex all right gentlemen crosstalk
rules in effect that means you can jump
in anytime you want and i always
appreciate it
okay let's go to beijing victor the
words that you know
the world must change china or china
will change us how do you interpret that
because
many commentators in foreign policy in
the foreign policy
world found his speech at the nixon
library
a bit bewildering because it's taking
today's circumstances
in the post-cold war and kind of
reverting back to it using the same kind
of language
and i want to talk about the ideological
angle to it too so i mean
china will is changing us how do you
react to that
well first of all i think my pompeo
speech at the
richard nixon presidential library was
an insult
to the nixon political legacy
and it's an insult to the china-u.s
relations for
more than 41 years now talking about
change i would say no
other country has changed more than
china has over the past
40 years and if the changes are good
for chinese people's interests of course
i would welcome
whatever changes we can bring along if
the changes
are to stop china's economic rise i
think all the chinese people will unite
behind the chinese government to oppose
and fight against
those changes i think what pompeo is
talking about
is that china should no longer develop
and china should give up the right of
peaceful rise and this is what the
chinese people can never accept
china need changes the more the better
if the changes will change china for the
better
and will improve the living standards of
the chinese people
and these changes are what china are
pursuing
but these changes are exactly the
opposite of what people like pompeo
are wishing for so we are at a very
important crossroad in
in world history and china's economic
development
is a mega trend no one can stop
china's economic development okay daniel
how do you how did you react to mike
pompeo's speech at the nixon library
because
a lot of people in a surprising number
and said is this
this is a drawing a line in the sand is
is that what we need
right now and is that is his message go
ahead
i think first of all the reason that he
chose that venue
is because back in the 1970s when
kissinger and nixon opened up the door
to u.s china relations
i think there was an acknowledgment at
the time or at least a hope
that what might happen is that there
would not only be a peaceful rise which
of course
everyone wants and everyone agrees with
generally
but they also were presuming that if
there was enough exposure to the west
and if there was a good relationship
between the us and china and the west
more generally
that you know china would gradually
liberalize politically
and it would change into something other
than what it was
of course that didn't happen and i think
the reason that he chose that venue is
because
if he had known that maybe that wasn't
going to happen
that maybe he would have thought twice
about exactly how he did what he did
back then
but that all said i think the u.s
government the u.s people
they certainly acknowledge that china is
a
very important and significant country
it's not going anywhere
i don't think the emir the american
government no matter what its com
composition would dream of suggesting
that china is not going to
continue its rise i think that it's
clearly an unstoppable train no one
even if there was a desire to do that no
one would be capable of doing it
so i think it's it's really an
acknowledgement of where we are
in sino-us relations at the present time
you know victor i i thought mike pompeo
misinterpreted richard nixon's opening
because
his if you look at the the historical
record
we have to remember this was in the
middle of the cold war we
and there was a final acknowledgement in
in
in the washington elites that there was
a rift between the soviet union and
china
and the nixon's um gambit was to get
to triangulate to get in there and and
to work
all have all three characters work
players work it simultaneously and it
actually worked to the benefit of all
three
okay but i mean mike pompeo was
interpreting as a child
that nixon's intent was to change the
internal order
of china and i think that's a
misrepresentation of the historical
record
this is about foreign policy go ahead
absolutely i actually had the great
honor and privilege of working
for richard nixon when he visited china
in 1985 as a private citizen
and we traveled together to several
cities in china in addition to beijing
nixon impressed me a great deal with his
vision
with his historical perspective and also
what is caring
for china-u.s relations so i think what
mike pompeo did
in the nixon presidential library is a
sacrilege
it's really an insult of the nixon
historical
legacy now i think what the united
states needs to do
is to figure out a way to get along with
china whether u.s is bigger than china
or whether china is bigger than u.s it
doesn't matter that much
the key is for china the united states
the two largest economies in the world
they need to get along with each other
they need to figure out a way
to deal with each other's differences
for example with respect
rather than going to each other's
jungler rather than
trying to wrestle the other side down to
the ground
because that's not possible the more
pressure people like pompeo put on china
the more resilient china becomes and the
more the chinese people will rally
behind the chinese communist party now
talking about the chinese communist
party
it's the largest the political party in
the world with more than
93 million members so i don't think
pompeo really knows what he's talking
about the chinese
people are really very much united with
the communist party of china
why because they improve the living
standards of the chinese people
they fight off the coronavirus they save
people in the middle of the corona virus
even those people in their 90s for
example this
is why the communist party of china in
china earns a lot of credentials
and also respect and support from the
chinese people
so i think whatever wishes my pompeo may
have
his mission is a mission of futility
okay daniel one of the things i find
very curious and
it kind of dovetails in with the rise of
this pandemic
is that for some reason um the united
states
with its current political order and the
political order in china run by the
communist party as we've just heard here
all of a sudden they can't coexist it's
really quite remarkable i mean
they coexisted for 70 years but over the
last four months all i hear
is communist china the communist party
of china is this
thrown into the media here i mean as if
it's something new
it's not new how do you explain that
well the part that's new
as everybody understands at least here
in america
is that the trump administration really
is no longer
taking china at its word that it's going
to do certain things
we know for example that in the obama
administration
there was an effort to you know stop
cyber intrusions etc back in 2015
she and obama had agreed and then you
know a month or two later they were back
at it so
i think there's an acknowledgment that
the gloves are off that something
fundamental has to change in the
relationship
and that china is no longer going to
quote have its way
with america whether it is vis-a-vis
trade
or in terms of cyber intrusions or the
theft of intellectual property
the difference is now that the trump
administration has basically said this
will not stand any longer
and we don't care if it has an impact on
the bilateral relationship
something fundamental has to change now
i don't agree
with trump about very much at all but i
do agree that it's
important to tackle you know very
fundamental
aspects of international relations and
this is one of those i mean
clearly the the nature of that
relationship could not continue going on
the way that it was
and to trump's credit uh although i'm
not accustomed to crediting him for much
uh i think that it ultimately will prove
to be useful
that the gloves are off and that there
will be something fundamental that will
change in this relationship it has to
yeah and daniel that having said that
then if the gloves are off the gloves
are off to both sides right
because i mean you know victor you know
i i i'm not in the intelligence
community and i cannot speak with
authority here
but i i i i take it as a default that
the
countries spy on each other and the more
more powerful and richer
more resources you have the more you're
going to apply it but the way the
american media is always spinning and i
said only china is doing this only china
doesn't
and there's it's not never mentioned
that this is part of statecraft
okay i'm not going to vouch for the
chinese government anymore then i'm
going to vouch for the u.s
government considering the weapons of
mass destruction in iraq i mean they
forever destroyed their reputation with
lots of people
like me so victor the gloves are off for
both sides that's fair
we're talking about cyber espionage just
read the book or the information coming
out of edward snowden
and i think we will have a very
comprehensive and complete picture of
what the u.s government has been doing
in terms of espionage or cyber espionage
now to
accuse china of doing that while
whitewashing what the us government has
been doing
is really in doubting in fantasy
and i don't think people in germany for
example in other parts of europe will
believe
what washington is talking about and
i would say uh the us way of manhandling
a great leading tech company like huawei
really reveals to the fullest extent
that the us cannot tolerate a company
which is better than its own
which is more outstanding than the song
which is the leader
in the 5g and it's not only trying to
kill huawei but it's rallying
all its allies trying to kill huawei but
they forget
that by killing huawei the americans are
not going to benefit because
this will drag down the u.s rollout
of the 5g network as well as the
applications to be built on top of the
5g network it will be a net loss
to the united states and eventually it
may force china
to really become completely self-reliant
in terms of semiconductor
so it may actually uh ring the
death knoll for the u.s semiconductor
industry
so i don't think people like pompeo or
abandon for example
on navarro they know what they are
talking about they want to do one thing
they don't care about the consequences
but the consequences will catch up with
them
this is how china-u.s relations
are played out right now and anything
washington will do with its gloves are
or without this gloves arm
there will be consequences and if i
don't expect
that anyone can wrestle down china onto
the ground go ahead
before we go to the break go ahead
daniel yeah if i could just jump in on
this
actually in 2017 i wrote a book on cyber
espionage called virtual terror
so i do know a thing or two about this
peter you're absolutely right
all states engage in this type of
behavior
i think the objection here is the scale
and the scope and the the absence of
consequences as a result of the actions
that
are often taken on the chinese side
obviously the us
uh is very active in this space as well
jump in here we have to go to a hard
break and after that heartbreak we'll
continue more discussion on u.s chinese
relations stay with rt
[Music]
welcome back to crosstalk where all
things are considered i'm peter level to
remind you
we're discussing whether china is now
the enemy
[Music]
okay let's go back to daniel again you
were talking about uh cyberspace uh
before we went to the break go ahead
i just wanted to pick up on one point
that victor had made regarding huawei
the objection the us government has to
huawei is because of the linkages
between huawei
and the chinese government if huawei was
strictly a commercial entity i don't
think there would be much to object
about
and i also believe that having taken the
actions that it's taken on huawei
it's going to encourage american
companies to actually do more in this
space
in 5 and g and i do think that
ultimately that will be the net result
okay well it's very interesting i think
i think victor has already kind of
alluded to it is that
the way we're going we're going to have
a two internet we're going to have you
know
you one country is going to choose to be
on one platform and another is going to
choose on another
and it doesn't look very good for the us
because in in in europe i mean for
example the germans are really pushing
really hard back but they want to make
their own decision
on this this on uh huawei and we have
the uk already come on i want to switch
gears a little bit here i want to go
back to something that pompeo said
i'm going to direct this to you victor
china ripped off our prized intellectual
property
and trade secrets costing millions of
jobs across
america i find i'm really getting tired
of this argument here
um it was um the captains of american
industry that decided where they were
going to make do their manufacturing and
they a lot of it went to china went to
mexico went to other countries
vietnam it went to a lot of different
countries here but to blame china for
stealing jobs i find that really quite
galling and it's not in accordance with
um with verifiable facts i would also
say
that it's missed a lot is that american
productivity actually
increased amazingly and it was uh
allowed to cut jobs so i mean we have a
productivity issue
and then moving assets into foreign
markets here i don't see how that is
china's fault china benefited from and
shareholders of american companies
immensely benefited from it go ahead
victor
absolutely as of now china is already
the largest
patent producer in the world larger than
the united states
and china has a great vested interest in
protecting rpr rights
for china itself for its companies as
well as for companies
throughout the world and the chinese
economic transformation
over the past 40 years is really
achieved
by the great contribution and hard work
and hard labor of the chinese people
including me
we really uh take a rest
for weekends we really take holidays off
for example we keep working
and this is the reason fundamental
reason for the higher
economic productivity in china and i
think
if you compare the discipline or the
work
ethics of the chinese people versus many
other countries
you will see why chinese economic
development has been so rapid over the
past 40 years
and hopefully it will continue to accuse
china of rpr
rights theft is really parking at the
wrong tree
as a matter of fact there are more
litigations
between and among american companies
against the american companies
american companies against korean
companies french companies etc
in terms of intellectual rights
infringement
intellectual rights problems are not
unique to china
and the chinese government has never had
any state policy
to encourage theft of rpr rights for
example
so i think this is purely fabrication
for the u.s government try to
focus on china's rpr problem as if for
example
china made the great economic
transformation over the past
40 years because of the theft of rpr
nothing can be further from the truth as
this
allegation you know kenya one of the
things i mean you know you and i are
you know they're all americans here and
and you know
i think it's fair to say we remember the
cold war pretty well okay
uh we betray our age um but it but that
that conflict was ideological and and
largely
military of course there were the
periphery um
um um uh flare-ups uh that were they
were a confrontation but the two
countries never
and that was a rule would never go after
each other here
but china is a very different country
than the soviet union because the soviet
union was never an economic powerhouse
it threatened
west i mean militarily it had some
pretty good stuff but
economically had artarky it didn't have
much trade i mean china is a very
different um uh animal if i can say than
the soviet union was
the united states just simply isn't used
to having a peer
and i think that's one of the things
that's kind of an annoying at the
the inner core of the the elites because
you know this is a different country
it's very powerful it's very rich and it
is on a trajectory
communism ended because it was in the
soviet union
for a variety of reasons okay and again
you know just pointing it you know
communist party of china that to me
doesn't say anything okay said something
to me about the soviet union
so the question is what's different here
is the u.s is not
is not uh accustomed to having a real
great power
rival go ahead daniel yeah i think
there's some truth in that let me
address it in a second i just want to go
back to something that victor said and
you said earlier i frankly don't
understand
why american companies are still
operating in china
and i do agree that uh they have largely
themselves to blame for making china the
manufacturing epicenter of the world
they and along with other lots of other
western companies they didn't have to do
that
but they chose to do it and then they
stayed there and even though there are
draconian operating
environments operating in china they'd
still choose to stay there which they
wouldn't do probably for any other
country so i do
wonder why that is still the case now in
answer to
your other question i do agree with you
that the u.s is unaccustomed to having a
global peer if you will and i think you
know frankly a lot of people here might
be a little bit concerned
that china has risen so quickly continue
to rise
so quickly that you know it's not far
behind the us and a lot of arenas
that said i think they would like to
believe
the americans would like to believe that
there's going to be some sort of a level
playing field
in terms of how we embrace and how we
operate by the same set of global rules
and norms
and i don't know that china is
necessarily so accustomed to operating
on that basis
china is much more accustomed to
creating
its own environment creating its own
alternative reality
in terms of the way it sees the world
and operating as it would like to
operate at home
abroad that is going to be very
difficult for it
to continue to do there's already a
backlash from the belt and road
initiative for having done so
and a lot of people are saying i'm not
sure i want this to continue
for a final point on that in 2018 pew
had the pew center had a very excellent
survey
where they surveyed 26 000 people from
25 countries
and basically 63 say they would like the
u.s to continue to lead
only 19 percent envisioned a world in
which china was the leader
okay victor i mean we heard the words
norms in rules
and as in in terms of the international
order
and i'm gonna have to push back against
daniel a little bit here i mean the
illegal invasion of
iraq the illegal presence of american
troops in syria
the illegal overthrow of the government
of libya um
the illegal overthrow of the democratic
elected government in ukraine
how in the world can people in the west
talk about norms and rules
you know i think uh washington probably
is accustomed
to violating all kinds of norms and
rules
if it suits their purposes and accuse
countries like china
of violating international norms if um
america feels threatened now coming back
to
daniel's point why multinational
companies want to come to china and
refuse to leave for example
because china now is the biggest
consumer market in the world
larger than that of the united states so
if you are a company if you run the
company
you cannot commit corporate suicide by
disregarding
the largest consumer market in the world
you need to produce in china
to get close to the market to know the
preferences of the chinese consumers
and you also need to leverage off on the
highest
quality infrastructure and connectivity
in china
so that your production can be at
lower cost and faster rate of turnaround
so that you can sell to all parts of the
world
including selling back to the united
states this is the attraction of china i
don't think
in the immediate future any other
country can replace china
as the biggest attraction for corporates
if they pursue corporate profitability
as their bottom line i think a lot of
people are if i could just say
uh pleased i think a lot of american
companies are asking themselves if they
can actually afford to stay in china
and over the last two decades i've
spoken with many companies
who have told me about the difficulty
they've had operating there they
originally went there of course for
exactly the reason you say victor
they wanted to be able to uh you know
tap into that 1.2 at the time maybe 1.4
billion people now
the question is you know is the cost uh
you know worth the potential benefit
a lot of companies are having second
thoughts about that well i think
well you know i think that you know i
want to make i want to make sure my
viewers don't misunderstand me here
i i i like the idea of bringing supply
chains back to the united states this
pandemic shows
the necessity of doing that but i don't
i don't think that
it is a a lose-lose i think it's a
win-win
that all countries safeguard supply
chains when it comes to certain
elements of their economy i think that's
that's called that's um
self-defense that's protecting your
sovereignty my
gripe is is that you know constantly
criticizing china
um uh for stealing our jobs when the
when the u.s itself allowed itself to be
open to vulnerabilities and i think you
know i would like to see an in
a congressional investigation into that
why'd you sell your country out
okay because that's the other side of
the coin here
the western media doesn't like the touch
here because well
the media is controlled by very powerful
people that are involved in this kind of
activity here so i mean we have to be
much more transparent
in what's going on here not just blaming
china victor
how is the relationship how should it
move forward
and how do you think it will move
forward and then we'll ask daniel the
same question go ahead victor
no i think uh china-u.s relations will
go further down
between now and november the 3rd and
between november the 3rd to uh
january the 20th 2021 i'm afraid
that america will be damned if trump
loses america will be done if trump
wins so there will be great chaos
in the united states
daniel the same question go ahead right
i don't know that the foundation that
has been laid over the last three plus
years is likely to change regardless
who's in the white house come january
20th
i think the stakes are going to continue
to be higher and i do agree with victor
that we can expect things to get a
little
a little worse uh in the next several
months that all said
i do think there will ultimately become
an equilibrium between the two powers
with the recognition
that they have to find a way to get
along the stakes are simply too high
and i wouldn't be surprised actually if
the chinese government actually prefers
a second trump presidency
because that will continue the disarray
and the fragmentation on the part of the
west
a biden presidency would probably result
in
some sort of a healing in that regard
between the u.s
and its many allies okay those are very
um
thoughtful thoughts from both of you
that's all the time we have i want to
thank our viewers
uh for watching us here at rd and i want
to thank our our guests in beijing and
in stamford
see you next time and remember crosstalk
[Music]
rules